so to a certain degree this is a flaw we
all share you know all of us will take a
thing more seriously care more about it
when we or someone close to us is
involved in it none of us are capable of
absolute
altruism or perfect empathy but if we
have
absolutely no concern for the tragedies
that befall others even while demanding
vocal and unending sympathy
whenever we are the one suffering
misfortune then we've gone far beyond
the universal flaw of fallen humans
everywhere in that case
we're sociopaths or even worse than
sociopaths if we outwardly applaud and
encourage
bad things when they happen to others
while still pulling the woe is me card
should we ever get a taste of our own
medicine
many of our politicians in dc quite
clearly fall into this second category
representative alexandria caser cortez
has
especially provided an illustration of
what happens when
when when that naturally imperfect
capacity for empathy gives way to
full-on sociopathy aoc was talking to
her fans on instagram
uh instagram live last night and the
fact that she has
fans to talk to on instagram is a
problem in and of itself but
she began describing in dramatic and
tearful terms
the trauma that she suffered during the
capital hill riots
the description was replete with visual
demonstrations
plenty of uh cinematic dramatic pauses
and all the rest of it let's uh listen
to some of this
like i'm here and the bathroom door
starts going like this
like the bathroom doors behind me or
rather in front of me and i'm like this
and the door hinges right here
and i just hear where is she where is
she
and um this was the moment
where i thought
everything was over
um
and the weird thing about moments like
these is that you lose
all sense of time um
in retrospect um maybe
it was four seconds maybe it was five
seconds maybe it was ten seconds
maybe it was one second i don't know it
felt like
my brain was able to have so many
thoughts in that moment between these
screams and these yells
of where is she where is she and so
i go down and i just
i mean i thought i was going to die
and it gets even more dramatic from here
next she began to describe
what in who she was thinking about as
she confronted her own mortality turns
out she was thinking about the american
people
and comforted by the knowledge that her
work would be continued by those who
come after her
let's listen to that and i had a lot of
thoughts you have a lot of thoughts
i think when you're in a situation like
that
um and like also one of those thoughts
that i had was you know i just happened
to
you know be a spiritual person and be
raised in that context and i
really just felt like you know
if this is the plan for me um
then people will be able to take it from
here
um i had a lot of thoughts
but that was the thought that i had
about you all
um
i felt that um
if this was the journey that my life was
taking
that i felt that things were going to be
okay
um now she also said that she simply
cannot
move on from this trauma and anyone who
demands that we move on
is acting like an abuser she said that
she has been sexually assaulted before
in her life and she compared
uh those who who wish to move past the
capital riots
to her own sexual abuser and if all that
wasn't enough for one instagram live
chat aoc also also threw the capitol
police under the bus
the very people who put themselves on
the line to protect her she tells us
about one of the police officers who
came to take her to safety and she said
that she was
scared of him because he was being mean
about it and he was yelling
yes he was yelling it's almost like you
know there was a mob of people this guy
was trying to deal with and he didn't
have time for pleasantries
seems understandable to me but aoc
thought and still thinks that it's quite
suspicious
and was happy to tell us about that the
media of course ate all this up
insisting that her description of the
riot was emotional and compelling and
demanding uh
and that it was demanding of our
attention and affirmation
and under normal circumstances i would
have little problem with anything that
she said aside from the part where she
smeared the men who were protecting her
i have a problem with that but the rest
under normal circumstances
i would say okay well that's how she
felt that's how she felt
but her description of the fear she felt
and so on
um you know it would provoke no protest
for me if not for the fact
that this same woman had spent the last
several months ignoring excusing and
romanticizing
the very same kind of chaos that she in
turn fell victim to
now i've played this before but let's
remind ourselves
so i think it could be helpful too let's
remind ourselves what aoc
said about blm rioting back in may
let's listen to that if you're trying to
call for the end of unrest
but you don't believe health care is a
human right if you're afraid to say
black lives matter if you don't
if you're too scared to call out police
brutality
then you aren't asking for an end of
unrest you are asking for
injustice to continue and for your
people to continue to endure
the violence of poverty the violence of
a lack of housing access
the violence of police brutality and not
say a damn thing that's what you're
asking for
so if you're out here calling for the
end of
unrest then you better be calling for
health care as a human right
you better be calling for accountability
in our policing you better be supporting
community review boards
you better be supporting uh
you know the end of housing
discrimination you better be standing
up to for-profit real estate developers
that are intimidating people and trying
to evict them from their homes
that's what you better be calling for
because if you don't call for those
things
and you're asking for the end of unrest
all you're asking for
is the continuation of quiet oppression
okay
yeah if you want rioting then it means
that you just want oppression to
continue you want
quiet oppression to continue and you
have no right to call for the end of
unrest
uh uh unless you want unless you call
out real estate developers
the whole list of demands you know so
but what she's doing here of course is
she's completely ignoring and erasing
the people in these communities actual
human beings
who are affected by this injured by a
damaged bike killed
by the unrest as you call it but for her
it's all academic
so sure we could get around to caring
about that but first i've got a whole
list of issues we need to uh discuss
first
note that she said all of that only two
days after a police prince
precinct was invaded and burned to the
ground
and on the same day that she recorded
that video she also shared an image on
her instagram
giving people advice on how to protest
safely
and this advice advice included things
like wear non-descript
solid colored solid solid colored
clothing
uh cover identifying tattoos
she exhorted protesters to put their
phone on airplane mode and not to bring
anything they don't want to be arrested
with
the point of this advice quite
explicitly was to help people commit
crimes
and to engage in mob violence without
getting caught or
while at least limiting their legal
liability if they are caught
and this is the stance she had towards
riding all through the summer two
billion dollars in damage 25 people
killed
the only people she condemned throughout
all of that were those who wanted the
violence to end
those who wanted to be safe in their own
communities again
but the shoe ends up on the other foot
and she comes face to face with the kind
of anarchy that she fomented and
encouraged and she responds by crying
and pointing fingers and
demanding sympathy and understanding
from the whole world
what happened to her is the greatest
crime in history a staggering tragedy
because it happened to her as for the
violence death and destruction visited
upon average americans
the convenience store owners who saw
their businesses incinerated the retail
employees whose places of work were
ransacked
the neighbors who were too afraid to
leave their homes because of the mayhem
outside
the cancer-stricken children huddling in
fear in their cancer centers
while blm riders smashed the windows
downstairs
the woman in rochester who was beaten by
two by fours
while trying to stop looters from
destroying her business the retired
police captain shot dead
left to bleed out in the street random
pedestrians harassed and assaulted and
so on
as for all of them aoc has no concern
doesn't care
never said a word about them ever still
has not never even acknowledged them
in fact she applauds their victimization
she sits back at a distance and
pontificates about
their suffering and declares that their
suffering is worth it because it's all
in service to a good cause
because we're sticking it to those real
estate developers
yeah i mean so they burn down apartment
complexes
that that'll really that'll really that
you know that'll really show the real
estate developers no no
well the problem is that they're people
are going to live in those homes actual
regular people
aoc doesn't care about them she doesn't
give a damn about them
you know it's all for a good cause what
is that cause exactly
and how does how does this advance it
well she can't say precisely nobody ever
could
all she was sure of is that two billion
dollars of property damage and 25 people
dead
wasn't enough to earn condemnation
indeed anyone who condemned it
was racist and then one day she gets an
up close and personal look
at what rioting is and what it feels
like on the ground and she sees that
it's not just
unrest it's terrifying
she was fortunate enough to get that
look have that experience as a heavily
protected public figure with cops around
to whisk her to safety
which they did not not that she has any
gratitude for those people who protected
her of course
but the fact remains that she had that
protection you know who didn't have that
protection how about the elderly man in
kenosha who went to stop the
blm riders from looting his mattress
store only to be attacked
bashed over the head and left lying on
the sidewalk with a broken jaw
he had no protection he had no defense
after the fact either from people like
aoc
she didn't give a damn about him or
anyone else any of the thousands of
others
victimized in similar ways over the
summer quite the contrary she
romanticized
the sort of violence that he fell victim
to
while her democrat pals helped to bail
out the rioters and put them back on the
street to do it all again the next day
she wants us now to forget all that and
focus on her
and her own alleged trauma that really
is the motto she lives by isn't it
forget all that and focus on me hey guys
i feel like we're not
talking about me enough here
but sorry aoc a lot of us are just not
going to play that game
we're not we have no doubt that what you
experienced was quite unpleasant
not as unpleasant as being beaten or
brutalized or shot dead
as so many americans were during the blm
riots but
unpleasant all the same maybe if you
admitted your role in normalizing and
encouraging this sort of violence and
apologized for it
and held yourself to account then we
could make some progress
we could get somewhere but you won't do
that
you aren't capable and so you just can't
get the sympathy
you desire well i hope you enjoyed that
clip from the matt wall show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe
button right down there so you can stay
up to date on all of our future content